نحن في وسط مخيم خان يونس للاجئين حيث هذه
الاليات التي كانت تعث خرابا في هذه
المنطقه ودمرت البنيه التحتيه بشكل كبير
اضافه الى تدمير عدد كبير من المنازل
الفلسطينيه بعد ان وصلت الاليات الى هذا
المكان وقامت بحمله التدمير الواسعه
والكبيره كما تشاهدون في الصوره نحاول ان
نقترب اكثر بالصوره في هذه المنطقه خاصه
منطقه المعسكر والتي كانت اليات الاحتلال
تتواجد في هذا المكان اطلقت قذائفها
باتجاه منازل المواطنين احرقت منها عددا
كبيرا ودمرت عددا كبيرا ايضا وايضا وصلت
هذه الاليات الى وسط المخيم واطلقت النار
باتجاه المواطنين عدد كبير من الشهداء
ارتقوا جراء غارات الاحتلال وعدوان
الاحتلال في هذه المنطقه بعض الشهداء تم
دفنهم في المناطق التي عثر الناس عليهم
فيها وكذلك عدد من الاصابات تم نقلها
حديثا الى مستشفى ناصر بعد ان انسحبت
جزئيا قوات الاحتلال من هذه المنطقه كما
تشاهدون حاله التدمير الواسعه والكبيره
التي لحقت بالبنيه التحتيه لحقت بمنازل
المواطنين هنا الان مسجد الامام
الشافعي على ما يبدو اليات الاحتلال وصلت
الى هذا المسجد ايضا
وتمركزت بالقرب منه الشارع هذا كان كويس
حذرونا منه طلعنا منه جينا خمسه ايام مش
عارفين دورنا وين ولا واحد عارف انت بس
واقف انت في منطقه كويسه هي الدمار هنا
كمان في نص المعسكر يا عمي ولا واحد عارف
داره مع وصولنا الىى باحات مستشفى ناصر
قبل قليل ما زال نقل الشهداء مستمر
وانتشال هؤلاء الشهداء من مناطق مختلفه من
معسكر خان يونس بعد انسحاب وتراجع اليات
الاحتلال من المكان شهيدان يصلان في هذه
اللحظات الى مستشفى ناصر ايش اللي جبتوه
قبل شوي شهدين كانوا في الشارع في الشارع
السماع اسمه جبناهم مرميين على الارض
ولقينا مرا في بيت في بلوك
جيم ها ثلاث ايام الحمد لله لقيناها عايشه
جبناها احنا والاسعاف اه في ش هذا في
الشوارع بال اكيد امبارح حوالي 24 شهيد
جبناهم من الشوارع الان حوالي عشرات
الشهداء في
الشوارع خلال الايام السابقه وصلت لمجمع
اصابات عديده واصابات بليغه جدا وحرجه وتم
التعامل معها من قبل الطواقم الطبيه
اصابات كثيره وصلت الى المجمع خلال عشره
ايام
السابقه وخلال الحصار
اي على مجمع ناصر الطبي وصل لدينا تقريبا
450 اصابه جل الاصابات من المدنيين
والاطفال والنساء وكثير منهم من مراكز
الاواء النازحين وعدد شهداء الذين وصلوا
157 شهيدا وصل مجمع ناصر الطبي من تاريخ
211 حتى هذه اللحظه اوضاع كارثيه وصعبه
يعيشها مستشفى ناصر في ظل توافد الاصابات
والشهداء الى داخل هذا المستشفى المحاصر
من قبل اليات الاحتلال خلال الايام
الماضيه مما ينذر بكارثه صحيه تحيق بهذا
المستشفى اسماعيل ابو عمر قناه الجزيره
خان يونس